and then the next thing we did our next  thing i did was i made this cute little  bench so my kids were little they would  sit here do homework talk to me whatever  um and you can see i use it for storage  of laundry but i have two sets of  drawers one for you can see it's  outgrown giveaway clothes and the other  one  is outgrown hand-me-down clothes so  kit comes out of the laundry you can  easily remember as a mom that oh yeah  those pants were too small for my kid or  whatever you can just drop them right in  the drawer  each one of my kids also so i also did  this two level laundry hanger system so  up here are my extra hangers and here's  where i hang the clothes while i'm  laundering and and every kid has a  hanger color so then i know like for  example i can see that amelia probably  has a lot of dirty laundry because she's  a lot of extra hangers whereas hannah  for example she has none so her laundry  is either all put away or her closet is  full of empty